you were at
Princeton uh with aspirations to be a
theoretical physicist yeah um What
attracted you to physics and why did you
change your mind and not become why why
you're not Jeff bz's the famous
theoretical physicist so I loved physics
and I studied physics and computer
science and I was proceeding along uh
along the physics path I was planning to
majure in physics and I wanted to be a
theoretical physicist and I and the
computer science was sort of something I
was doing for fun I really loved
it um and I and I was very good at the
the programming and doing those things
and I enjoyed all my computer science
classes
immensely but I really was determined to
be a theoretical physicist I it's why I
went to Princeton in the first place it
was definitely and then I realized I was
going to be a mediocre theoretical
physicist and there were um uh there
were were a few people in my classes
like in quantum mechanics and so on who
they could effortlessly do things that
were so difficult for me and I realized
like you know there are a thousand ways
to be smart and to be a really you know
theoretical physics is not one of those
fields where the uh you know only the
top few percent actually move the
state-of-the-art forward it's one of
those things where you you have to be
really uh just your brain has to be
wired in a certain way and there was a
guy named um one of these people who was
uh convinced me he didn't mean to
convince me but just by observing him he
convinced me that I should not try to be
a theoretical physicist his name was Yos
Santa and Yos
Santa um was from Sri Lanka and he's he
was one of the most brilliant people I'd
ever met my uh friend Joe and I were
working on a very difficult partial
differential equations problem set one
night and there was one problem that we
worked on for 3 hours mhm and we made no
Headway
whatsoever and we looked up at each
other at the same time and we said Yos
Santa so we went to Yos Santa's dorm
room yeah and he was there he was almost
always there and we said y Sant we're
having trouble solving this uh partial
differential equation would you mind
taking a look and he said of course by
the way he was the most humble most kind
person and so he took our he looked at
our problem and he stared at it for just
a few seconds maybe 10 seconds and he
said cosine and I said what do you mean
yant what do you mean cosign he said
that's the answer and I said no no no
come on and he said let me show you and
he took out some paper and he wrote down
three pages of equations everything
canceled out and the answer was cosine
and I said y Santa did you do that in
your head and he said oh no that would
be impossible possible a few years ago I
solved a similar problem and I could map
this problem onto that problem and then
it was immediately obvious that the
answer was cosine I had a few you know
you have an experience like that you
realize maybe being a theoretical
physicist isn't your isn't what you're
your your what the universe wants you to
be and so I switched to computer science
and um and you know that worked out
really well for me I enjoy it I still
enjoy it today yeah there's a particular
kind of intuition you need to be a great
physicist in applied to physics I think
the mathematical skill required today is
so high you have to be a worldclass
mathematician to be a successful
theoretical physicist today and it's not
you know it uh you probably need other
skills too intuition lateral thinking
and so on but without the without just
topnotch math skills you're unlikely to
be successful and visualization skill
you have to be able to really kind of do
these kinds of thought experiments and
if you want to truly great creativity
actually Walter Ison writes about you uh
it puts you on the same level as
Einstein that's very kind but I have I'm
an inventor if you if you want to boil
down what I am I'm really an inventor
and I look at things and I can come up
with atypical solution
and you know and then I can create
hundred such atypical solutions for
something 99 of them may not survive you
know scrutiny but one of those 100 is
like H maybe there is maybe that might
work and then you can keep going from
there so that kind of lateral thinking
that kind of uh inventiveness in a high
dimensionality space where the search
space is very large that's where my
inventive skills come that's the thing
I'm if if I I self-identify as an
inventor more than anything else yeah
and he describes in all kinds of
different ways Walter Ison does that uh
creativity combined with childlike uh
Wander that you've
maintain still to this day all of that
combined together is there like if you
were to study your own brain introspect
how do you think what's your thinking
process like we'll talk about the
writing process of putting it down on
paper mhm uh which is quite rigorous and
famous at uh Amazon but how do you when
you sit down maybe alone maybe with
others and thinking through this High
dimensional space and looking for
Creative Solutions a creative paths
forward is there something you could say
about that process it's such a good
question and I honestly don't know how
it works if I did I would try to explain
it I know it involves lots of wandering
yeah so I you know when I sit down to
work on a problem I know I don't know
where I'm going so to to go in a
straight line to be efficient efficiency
and invention are sort of at odds
because invention real invention not
incremental Improvement incremental
Improvement is so important in in every
Endeavor and everything you do you have
to work hard on also just making things
a little bit better but I'm talking
about real invention real lateral
thinking that re requires wandering and
you have to give yourself permission to
wander I think a lot of
people
um they feel like wandering is
inefficient and should you know like
when when I sit down at a meeting I
don't know how long the meeting is going
to take if we're trying to solve a
problem because if I did then I'd
already I i' know there's some kind of
straight line that we're drawing to the
solution the reality is we may have to
wander for a long time and I do like
group invention I think there's really
nothing more fun than sitting at a
whiteboard with a a n you know a group
of smart people and spitballing and
coming up with new ideas and objections
to those ideas and then solutions to the
objections and going back and forth so
like um you know sometimes you wake up
with an idea in the middle the night and
sometimes you sit down with a group of
people and go back and forth and both
things are really pleasurable and when
you wander I think one key thing is to
notice a good idea and to to to maybe to
notice the kernel of a good idea maybe
pull it that string cuz I don't think uh
good ideas come fully
formed 100% right there in fact when I
come up with what I think is a good idea
idea and it survives kind of the first
level of scrutiny you know that I do in
my own head and I'm ready to tell
somebody else about the idea I will
often say look it is going to be really
easy for you to find objections to this
idea but work with me there's something
there there's something there and that
is intuition yeah you because it's
really easy to kill new
ideas in the beginning because they do
have so many so many easy objections to
them so you need to uh you need to kind
of forwarn people and say look I know
it's going to take a lot of work to get
this to a fully formed idea let's get
started on that it'll be fun so you got
that ability to say cosign in you
somewhere after
all maybe not on math in a different
domain yeah there are a thousand ways to
be smart by the way and that is a really
like when I go around you know and I
meet people I'm always looking for the
way that they're smart and you find it
is that's one of the things that makes
the world so interesting and fun is that
it is not it's not like IQ is a single
yep Dimension there are people who are
smart in so such unique ways yeah you
just gave me a good response when
somebody calls me an idiot on the
internet you know there's a thousand
ways to be smart sir well but they might
tell you yeah but there are a million to
be ways to be done yeah right I feel
like that's a mark twn
quote